Republican congressman Devin Nunez is
suing Twitter and several of its users
for more than a quarter of a billion
dollars in a complaint obtained by Fox
News knew Nunez accuses Twitter of
shadow banning conservatives and
knowingly hosting and monetizing content
that is clearly abusive hateful into
famine Tory he is seeking two hundred
and fifty million dollars in
compensatory damages and three hundred
and fifty thousand dollars in punitive
damages and O'Keefe is in Washington
with details of the legal fight this is
a bit unusual at good morning it is
beyond a good morning in the lawsuit
congressman Nunez accuses Twitter of
censoring viewpoints it doesn't agree
with and serving as a portal for
defamation the longtime ally of
President Trump claims he's been a
victim of an orchestrated defamation
campaign that's interfere with his job
and now he wants Twitter and several
users to pay they spread this fake news
and the slanderous news on Fox News
Monday night California congressman
Devin Nunez said he has been attacked
relentlessly on Twitter by fake and
anonymous accounts the case were
basically making is is this was an
orchestrated effort Nunez the former
head of the House Intelligence Committee
is now suing the social media giant and
three users he claims they have defamed
him among the tweets he references in
the lawsuit is this one from a parody
account at Devon Nunez is mom in which
the anonymous user rights are you trying
to obstruct a federal investigation
again in another the user wrote when we
have questions about hookers or Vegas
strip clubs will call you okay Devon
Nunez and this tweet from political
consultant Liz Mayer where she calls him
dirty Devon the lawsuit also accuses
Twitter of shadow banning Nunez a
practice that allows users to still
tweet but no one sees their posts in
July President Trump tweeted that
Twitter was shadow banning prominent
Republicans calling it discriminatory
and an illegal practice at a
congressional hearing in September
Twitter CEO Jack Dorsey denied purposely
shadow banning we don't consider
political viewpoints perspectives or
party affiliation in any of our policies
or enforcement decisions they don't want
to call it shadow banning that's fine
they can call it whatever they want to
call it but the fact of the matter is is
people could not
my tweets all of this Nunez says
negatively impacted his re-election
campaign where he won by a narrow margin
and it's interfered with his ongoing
Russia investigation as a member of the
Intelligence Committee this is the first
of many lawsuits we have to hold all of
these people accountable because if we
don't our First Amendment rights are at
stake here
Twitter told CBS News it doesn't shadow
ban and certainly doesn't shadow ban
based on political viewpoints or
ideology the political consultant Liz
mayor declined to comment on the lawsuit
our legal analyst Ricky Clayman told us
that under current law internet sites
can't be sued for responsibility for
their content and even if Twitter could
Nunez is a public figure and it would be
extraordinarily difficult to win a case
like this gale all right Ricky knows
these things thank you very much Edie